Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That number
is 2192. David P There is a very wealthy caller
who doesn't like what I do and is going to
try to get me removed from YouTube. Listen to.
Speaker 4: This. Hey, punk ass kid. Hey, I'm
gonna call you, too, and tell them I'm going
back out. My support for them. If they don't
take down every post on YouTube that you've
made. Whoa. So don't be surprised. Monday after.
Ain't none of your lack on YouTube. Whoa. I'm a
very wealthy man. I pay a lot of money to
YouTube, You little pieces. Ways to spare.
Speaker 5: Wow. Wow.
Speaker 1: Well, we are going to
look into that very, very strongly. And I do hope
and pray that by the time you hear that voicemail,
all of our videos have indeed been removed from
YouTube. All right. So we'll look into that very
strongly. We have a fantastic bonus show for you
today. We are now learning about the judge who
is going to handle Donald Trump's arraignment
tomorrow. The judge is considered no nonsense.
We are going to talk about that. Number two, the
Twitter blue checkmarks for verified individuals
rather than people who just are signing up for
Twitter blue. What is happening? There is a major
drama involving The New York Times. It's crazy
what is going on with Twitter verification. And
it's the continued decline of Twitter, which
we will discuss. And lastly, Brittney Griner
is calling for the release of an American reporter
detained in Russia, much like she previously was.
It is all escalating. It is all building. And we
are talking about all of it on the bonus show.
Speaker 5: Oh, the bonus show where you want to
make money. Yeah. Everybody else that makes money
to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1:
Now, not only with an
anti-endorsement from Alex Jones,
but with an anti-endorsement from Candace Owens.
Speaker 2: David Pakman does not have a soul.
He doesn't have a soul.
Speaker 1: Okay, If that
anti-endorsement makes you curious about the
bonus show, then by all means, sign up at
Join PAC Mint.com. You can use the coupon code
indicted, but you have to spell it correctly.
Trump spelled it indicated when he posted about
being indicted. That won't work as a coupon code,
but the correctly spelled indicted will save
you big bucks at join Pacman dot com. I will
see you on the bonus show and then on tomorrow's
show. Then on the Trump arraignment livestream
and then on the Trump press conference live
stream. Much going on in the next 36 hours.